this being d23 it seemed like you might
want some new information and you might
want to hear about three new shows we're
doing but this reply so let's reveal the
first one mu night a new
action-adventure series coming to Disney
Plus a very famous Marvel character for
many years marc spector he was a
mercenary he was left for dead in the
Egyptian desert and he now may or may
not be infused with powers from khonshu
that moon God or he might just be crazy
it is something very unique and exciting
for us
miss Marvel Camilla Kon Muslim Pakistani
teenager from Jersey City is coming to
the MCU it is remarkably exciting for us
you will meet her in her Disney Plus
series and then you will see her in our
films she-hulk coming to Disney Plus
Bruce Banner is no longer the only Hulk
in the MCU Jennifer Walters is a Hulk
she's a lawyer and she's going to start
a show unlike anything we've done before
this is what Disney Plus is doing for
the MCU it is growing it is expanding it
thank you thank you so much that's what
we've got thank you so much everybody
appreciate it hey everybody it's Charlie
this is going to be my video for all the
big announcements on the Marvel phase
four series in the movies spin-offs this
is gonna be happening the next couple of
years
we're finally getting moon night so many
have you been asking for that in the
comments on all these videos for so long
it's only the tip of the iceberg he even
talked about which characters would show
up in Avengers 5 on the New Avengers
roster so we'll break it down and there
is a deal going on for Disney Plus right
now so I'll do a giveaway for signups
for that all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your favorite
new Marvel phase 4 series they announced
on the video I know you're all asking
for spider-man MCU Marvel Sony updates
I'll talk about that at the end of the
video - I've already done a couple
spider-man videos with all the
information that we have right now but
it's changing day to day so if we hear
more big news about it things change
don't worry I will cover it in a video
but breaking this all down top 9 style
starting with what if Marvel what if is
going to be 23 episodes long 1 episode
for every single MCU Marvel movie they
didn't say how many seasons it's going
to
for and if they'll do more what if
episodes for future MCU movies but I
assume that they will but they didn't
say whether it was gonna happen every
year because 23 episodes is a full
season of television so they might break
those episodes up and air them in a
couple of different blocks because we
also found out that they'll be airing
all the Marvel series episodes weekly on
Disney Plus instead of dropping them all
at once Netflix style during the what if
footage preview they had zombie Captain
America fighting Winter Soldier or
fighting Bucky I should say because it
was all happening during 1942 Peggy
Carter getting the Super Soldier Serum
I've talked about this before they
showed off a Comic Con teaser the new
stuff at d23 was a little bit different
a little more complete but because Peggy
Carter is British is a lot of you have
suspected a lot of you figured this out
a while ago they'll actually call her
Captain Britain so we are getting
Captain Britain in a Marvel production
just not the way you would expect they
also had footage of skinny Steve Rogers
in a world war 2 tank looking Iron Man
armor developed by Howard Stark it was
about as big as the Iron Monger suit
there was a version of T'Challa that
they showed off that looked like
star-lord as if he'll be the person who
has the father from another planet and
look at that star-lord back story number
8 Falcon and Winter Soldier had a big
preview they confirmed that Sharon
Carter agent 13 is coming to that series
they didn't say exactly what she'd be
doing but she'll be in all the episodes
Baron Zemo is gonna be the main villain
they also said that they're doing John
Walker u.s. agent from the comics number
7 Scarlet Witch invision got a really
big preview they actually have this
special concept r2 confirming that
they're basing it on the Tom King vision
run so if you haven't read that rush out
and read it because that series is all
about what happens when vision
constructs himself a nuclear family and
spoiler warning things do not go well so
obviously this TV version is gonna be a
little bit different because vision is
dead but if you look over on the left
side of this frame here in the preview
you see a shadow of Scarlet Witch with
her special tiara from the comics she's
wearing the full-blown Scarlet Witch
comic book costume envisioned with a
little light shining through his
forehead where the mine stone used to be
they confirmed that Darcy from the Thor
movies is going to cross over and be
part of the series and Monica Rambeau
but they didn't say what they would be
doing on this series they also announced
Kat
Rahan the actress will be playing their
nosy neighbor that just pokes into their
business when things get really weird
here's the big change though a lot of
you have suspected about this because
Scarlet Witch has reality-warping powers
in the comics and vision is dead in
present day they haven't brought him
back yet so what'll probably wind up
happening is is the twist on the Tom
King story is that Scarlet Witch will be
the one to construct this family with
vision for herself and this is what it
winds up looking like she just creates
this artificial reality and that's how
it crosses over with Doctor Strange into
the multiverse of madness because
remember Scarlet Witch is gonna cross
over into that movie herself in the plot
of Scarlet Witch envisioned the Wanda
vision TV show will directly influence
what happens during the Doctor Strange
sequel and I almost forgot to Randall
Parks Jimmy woo character from ant-man
and the wasp that funny FBI agent he's
also going to be on the Wanda vision TV
show too probably doing the same thing
just checking in on them say like why is
all this weird stuff happening here
Oh Scarlet Witch is warping reality
number six they talked about new teams
that are gonna show up in the movies and
the TV shows eventually so you have the
Ultimates they basically confirm I don't
know when they're gonna do blue Marvel
at some point but they're doing Monica
Rambeau
it'll all probably have something to do
with the spider-man far from home
post-credit scene with Nick Fury on the
sword Space Station they're gonna have
more cosmic threats to handle so that's
why that team will come together they
might put together a new version of the
defenders through Doctor Strange and I'm
talking about classic comic-book
defenders we all know that they're gonna
do Thunderbolts at some point Falcon and
Winter Soldier putting a team together
with Baron Zemo you have the ghost
character you have Jelena Bulova coming
out of the Black Widow movie who's sort
of the new version of Black Widow since
our version of NAT died during endgame
then there's the Illuminati eventually
once you get the x-men and the Fantastic
Four characters and it'll take a while
to get to Illuminati but you basically
have all the original members from the
comics now under the Marvel tent will
have the Fantastic Four pretty
straightforward just the classic roster
the x-men pretty straightforward as well
The Young Avengers maybe they'll call it
the champions if they don't want to
dilute the Avengers brand then you have
the new Avengers and big surprise Kevin
Feige confirming the kit harington's
black knight will show up on a future
Avengers roster is a really
amazing actor and this part came up in
the Eternals film that we're doing we
were so happy when he agreed to join it
and it is a part that could perhaps grow
into something else in the future so
number five kit harington's black knight
joining Avengers 5 he was a big Avengers
character in the 1960s avengers comics
he teamed up with him a whole bunch of
times and he was a longtime love
interest of the cersei eternals
character through the 80s the Eternals
movie will take place in the distant
past when they were created through
flashbacks and then in present day as
well so there will be Eternals walking
around on avengers teams in the future
but i was kind of surprised when he
started talking about Kit Harington
coming back for quote-unquote other
things meaning obviously bigger Avengers
level things number four the big moon
night reveal everybody freaking out
about this probably more than any of the
other news series love Kevin Feige geez
intro does he have powers or is he just
crazy he has multiple personality
disorder in the comics this panel is a
really good example of what that looks
like on screen the pie use it for a
little bit of comedy but he's mostly
known for being a Marvel night series so
he can get pretty hardcore think of it
as being more in the tone of the
daredevil Netflix series so the
daredevil character could show back up
during that because it's gonna be a
couple years before we get there so the
Netflix cooling-off period will be done
and they can use those Netflix
characters again here on the expanded
phase four schedule they released it's
on the timeline after the Hawkeye and
the Miss Marvel series that means it's
probably going to be coming out spring
2022 right around Black Panther - so
early theory because all the TV shows
are being released with the movies that
they're crossing over with the Black
Panther twos plot will have something to
do that helps set up the Moon Knight
series we also found out that they're
probably gonna do werewolf by night on
the moon night series because the moon
night character originated in the
werewolf by night comics so it makes
sense that he would also show up on the
series because they're going full-blown
werewolf they're doing blade so don't be
surprised if the new Knight character
crosses over with the blade movie or if
the blade movie happens right after the
moon night series and that's the movie
that it's crossing over with number
three there was the Miss Marvel series
they announced it's supposed to take
place in present day after avengers
endgame like everybody assumed she'll
also appear in the Captain Marvel sequel
which confirms that at least part of
that movies
gonna take place in present day instead
of just being another 90s period piece
they didn't say how they're gonna change
Kamala Khan's backstory or how her
powers are gonna work on the show
because nowhere in any of these
announcements the last couple of months
has there been any talk of Inhumans and
Kamala Khan is an inhuman in the comics
that's how she gets her powers through
the Terrigen mists and she just takes
the name Miss Marvel because she admires
the Captain Marvel character Kevin Feige
has only been talking about mutants the
x-men Deadpool characters so they might
just say MCU Kamala Khan is a mutant
with the X gene her ability to embroil
etal is kind of cartoonish so I don't
know how they're gonna alter that for
live-action so that it's not quite so
silly but it's wide open at theory
crafting obviously she would also cross
over to whatever young Avengers or
champions team-up that they do number
two there was a she-hulk TV show they
announced it's happening right after
moon night confirming my theory that
Marvel can use the Hulk characters on TV
because Universal still holds some of
the movie rights making it really
difficult for them to do a solo Hulk
movie Mark Ruffalo was tweeting about it
so yes I totally expect him to appear on
that she-hulk series to sort of set it
up obviously they have to explain her
origin story which will probably happen
on the TV series and will have to
involve something with Bruce Banner Hulk
also pretty solid bet that she's gonna
wind up on the next Avengers roster in
Avengers 5 just because she's powerful
enough and she's a good stand-in for
Bruce Banner Hulk if he takes a more
background cameo role in future movies
in number one big spider-man update is
spider-man watcher every day there's a
new rumor about what's going on between
Marvel and Sony over the fate of
spider-man in the MCU I already did a
video about those clips that Tom Holland
and Kevin Feige released them talking
about eulogizing the character it was a
fun run we had five films we told the
story we wanted to whether or not you
believe that because they're being very
political during their speech there
because conversations between Sony and
Marvel are ongoing and neither side
wants to cede any ground or give the
other side a big bargaining advantage so
that's why everybody is saying really
weird stuff making it sound like
everything is over so when we hear more
real information about that I will do
new updates but there were some rumors
about him signing a seven picture deal
being back in the MCU that's all false
there's still a lot of bad blood
between the two parties but they will
come back to the table eventually so
don't freak out too much congratulations
a mod gamer you're the giveaway winner
from my last big Marvel video please
email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your details
everybody click here to learn what's
going on with the spider-man character
in the MCU and click here for my
breakdown of the Black Widow footage in
the Marvel phase 4 trailer from this
past weekend thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]